i always thought it is strange
that the sector of pharmaceuticals is
one that is usually for profit
does this mean that the profit and loss
formula controls the decision of what
medicine to produce even for cancer
medication
they wanted to bring me to prison and i
wanted to steal some of my patents a lot
of people believe that there's a cure
for cancer but it's not true why do
ideas spread when there is proof against
it
there is a cure for cancer and that's
been known about for a long time
crashed into one of the towers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a very provocative subject that
allows folks to gain followers you could
make a fortune if you had a cure for
cancer if that's covered in a single
pencil that's a different stuff
could this mean that in order to make
more money
they suppress the discovery of cheap and
effective cures for cancer
i am human so deep down in my gut i have
the fear of death
fear for my death to an extent
and an extreme fear for the death of
those i love
a few years ago someone who is dear to
me was diagnosed with cancer
and death became very near
this pushed me to search for any cure or
treatment that could help
i found that much has been said about
this
there are people who claim they have
been cured by non-institutional or
alternative cures there are others that
claim that the pharmaceutical companies
have the cure for cancer
but they hide it in order to continue
profiting billions of dollars every year
from those who live with the disease
so in brief this hypothesis claims that
an effective cure for cancer
institutional or not
is not in the pharmaceutical company's
best interest because of profit
and this claim is not suspicious of a
company or two the suspect here is the
entire health institution globally
it is a dangerous accusation which
requires inspection and proof
in my research i met dr stanislav
borzinski one of the doctors that
claimed to have presented a cure for
cancer outside the traditional
institutional system and he says that
the system fought against him
in five of the patients with brain
tumors
the two more
disappear it's impressive
and unbelievable
[Music]
it says here that you have been
successfully curing cancer since the
1980s
well yes we are specializing in
treatment of terminal cancer
we see people coming to us from all over
the world and the main
thing is that they were told by their
doctors that there's nothing that can be
done for them
the cause of cancer are mutated genes
from about 80 to 650 mutations which
form a program they start about how to
make cancer we are identifying these
genes and we treat them and the
medications which i discovered they are
able to treat over 150 common genes and
you can get rid of tumors and present
the liver after
sounds like you basically cured cancer
can you tell me what was the response of
the medical community to your treatment
i went through some like 35 years of
vote and worth war
with very powerful organizations so they
wanted to bring me to prison for 270
years so they can steal my partners and
finally about four years ago we won and
i believe that we are beginning a
peaceful millennium
the question is who is the discoverer he
discovered will be
one of the largest to the company then
it will go right away if they discover
it a single person
who came to the united states was five
dollars of his possessions and built his
own research center pharmaceutical
factory in the clinic
well that's a different study
[Music]
according to the world health
organization
arab countries show a steep prize in the
number of cancer patients
in 2012 there was more than one million
deaths caused by cancer in the arab
world
and the region is expected to see an 80
increase in the number of patients
between the years 2020 and 2030.
millions of people need an effective
cure for cancer
a cure which some argue there is a
conspiracy to hide
the conspiracy is so huge that some
people argue it would not stay secret
for long
one of these people is david robert
grimes
do you think
there is a cover-up to hide an effective
cure for cancer
a lot of people believe that there's a
cure for cancer being suppressed by big
pharma because they'd lose all the money
that they get treating people and
they'll postulate all sorts of
strange things they claim cure cancer
that aren't profitable for big pharma
it's a nice story but it's not true
cancer isn't one disease cancer is a
family of over 200 known diseases some
of which respond to radiation some
respond to chemotherapy they're all very
different because they're all mutations
of different types of cells so the idea
of a single magic bullet for cancer is a
bit misguided secondly
you could make a fortune if you had a
cure for cancer half the people in the
world will eventually get cancer if
you're selling something to half the
people in the world it's highly
profitable and you can i'm sorry can i
just interrupt you there did you just
say that half of the people of the world
will eventually get cancer essentially
if you live long enough you roll a
genetic dice
every day you live you roll a little
chance of getting cancer if you live
long enough
your odds on getting cancer go up it's
not that the world is becoming more
carcinogenic we're getting cancer
because we're living longer i must say i
like the fact that you use statistics to
support your argument from that
perspective if there is indeed a
conspiracy to hide a cure for a variety
of cancers
how long will it take the world before
such a conspiracy is
uncovered
i actually looked a few years ago
at the probability of being able to keep
huge conspiracies uh
quiet i also looked at cancer and when i
crunched through the mathematics of that
at best if everyone was in on board the
conspiracy theory there are so many
people you would need
everyone who works in drug development
for cancer everyone who treats cancer
from an oncological point of view and
pretty much everyone in the
pharmaceutical industry that goes to
millions of people before you do too
much effort that even if everyone was as
good a secret keeper as a national
security agency in america you would at
best get maybe two or three years before
the whole thing was out of the bag
in the face of such a mathematical
impossibility
why does such a narrative persist for so
many years i think this is a story that
people tell themselves to give
themselves a feeling of power but i
think all the evidence is so
blazingly against us
why do ideas spread when there is proof
against it
because sometimes spreading an idea is
just easier than confronting the truth
you want to say it's
laziness
sometimes it is laziness
other times we choose to believe that
certain things are bigger than our
ability to change them
that's laziness
[Music]
it's mind-boggling
information travels
true or false
i'm
going to start
treating it with cannabis oil
it travels among people
people who know what they are talking
about
and people who have no idea but are
emotionally invested
but facts are not something you can pick
and choose from like a suit you want to
wear
after i talked to grimes i read an
article for him where the conspiracy
theory of the hidden cure of cancer is
described as the zombie theory it never
dies no matter how many times you kill
it
maybe people believe in such theories
because they lost faith in the system
or because they want to hold on to hope
especially the patients themselves
maybe someone who went through the
experience can explain why the smith
lives
glenn 7 is a cancer survivor and coach
who may have answers
why do you think the rumor of a cancer
cure cover-up is so pervasive i think
it's uh two parts
one is that it's a very provocative
subject that allows folks to
gain followers to
you know communicate about these various
kind of
conspiracy theories the other issue it's
the lack of
education
on the part of patients who are just not
seeking their knowledge from
the most reputable
sources
it's not to say that there's bad actors
in pharma there certainly have been but
if there's cancer cures then they would
be out there and available to the public
some people say that
the medication for
cancer like chemotherapy and
radiotherapy are as toxic as the disease
itself
one of the things that folks that may be
aligned with this conspiracy thinking
have to do with the fact that different
chemotherapeutics different drugs
and radiation oncology creates a pro
cancer environment it's really important
for the host the patient that's
undergoing these therapies to be well
protected there's a lot of things that
patients can do
to get through these toxicities with
less of these terrible side effects and
even
potentially reducing the long-term side
effects that is not communicated
as well as it should be so what can you
tell me about cancer cure research is
there an effective cure in sight
there is a cure for cancer and that cure
has been
known about
for a long time
and that's called prevention healthy
clean eating movement stress reduction
restorative sleep being aware of your
environment all these things play a
major factor
uh in in allowing cancer to
present
itself
what glenn said
means that prevention from cancer is
possible by following a healthy
lifestyle to avoid illness in general
there are also strange recipes some
people claim that can help reach the
same end
third of cancers can actually be
prevented by healthy lifestyle behaviors
that we do have control over dip half a
lemon in baking soda this combination is
effective in the ongoing struggle
against cancer easy anti-cancer protocol
and that is the baking soda and
maple syrup
and there are others who came up with
strange explanations about the causes of
the disease
i decided to go back to david and ask
him hey david
i need to ask you a few more questions
if you don't mind they're concerning the
cancer cure claims some people claim
that cancer is a fungus and they can
cure it with sodium bicarbonate is that
true
cancer is most definitely not a fungus
you can look at cancer cells under a
microscope they are very much human
cancer is you just a really warped
version of you it is not a fungus which
is an entirely different species so the
idea that you can treat cancer like it's
a fungus is unfortunately incredibly
misguided and can harm patients
i read also once that there was this
woman who claimed that she
cured her cancer by
daily injections of vitamin c
lioness polling won two nobel prizes one
in chemistry and one as a peace prize
and in the 70s he became obsessed with
the idea that vitamin c could cure the
cold that it could cure cancer that it
could cure aids everything
the problem is he was wrong
but because he was so famous and well
renowned this has become a myth that
won't die
unfortunately vitamin c does not cure
cancer
in fact vitamin c doesn't even work for
coals so these are the myths of
the cures there are other myths of the
causes like some people claim that
deodorants in microwave ovens can cause
cancer the x-rays the gamma rays they
have the ability to ionize what that
means is they can remove an electron
from your chemical bonds and when they
do that that can cause damage to your
dna which can eventually become cancer
but
the lower energy forms of light like
visible light and microwave cannot do
that it doesn't have the ability to
ionize
so it doesn't cause cancer
now do deodorants cause cancer well this
has been studied quite a bit too and
most of the data in fact all of the
solid data we have on this says no they
do not
so basically you make it sound as if
there is no uh
healthy diet or lifestyle that can
actually protect you from cancer
if you have a healthy diet if you're not
obese if you're not drinking too much
alcohol for example is a carcinogen
obviously if your general health is is
good you're rolling that dice of causing
harm a little bit less but again we have
to remember that cancer is largely
probabilistic you can live the
healthiest purest lifestyle and still
get cancer
for sure there are many conspiracies in
the world
sometimes questionable people get
together and plot something malicious
but any claim that there is a conspiracy
without the clear proof is just empty
words
there may be countless delusions that
one could believe
but still there is always only one truth
in ancient egypt the sky in the day was
called newt
and at night it was called moot
some say that this is the source of the
words mode in arabic and mortem in latin
the mean death
but death in ancient egypt had a
different meaning linked to the sunset
there is a sunrise later it's a cycle
and this i see as the only truth about
life
[Music]
[Music]
you